emma salut à tous on se retrouve donc
pour cette vidéo sur les joueurs
français et on va regarder donc une
partie de saint-amand donc ça a été le
joueur français le plus fort après la
mort de la bourdonnais et il a même été
considéré comme le meilleur joueur
mondial
on va dire de 1840 à 1843 donc meilleur
meilleur potentiel mondial quoi sont
donc de saint-amand non glacée une
partie qui jouait avec les pièces noires
contre george walker genre anglais
partie jouée à londres
et donc comme pas mal de joueurs de
cette époque on n'a pas énormément de
partie parce que il jouait surtout
pendant la régence il n'était pas leur
parti en angleterre et notaires et donc
d'ailleurs ça c'était parti jouer à
londres
donc ils allaient noir et c'est parti
donc ils jouent aux 4,5 et a écrit blanc
son adversaire le joug c3 donc on peut
comprendre qu'il a envie de jouer des
quatre c'est un peu comme comme dans la
tanzanie ça c'est cette ouverture en mai
mais quand ce deuxième coup et je dois
dire c'est plutôt moyen et réagit pas
mal etc et noir il fait des cinq direct
donc il prend le centre et donc l'idée
c'est qu'après pions francs dame prend
qui a été jouée en aparté comme ilyas
option c3 les blancs vont pas pouvoir
développer le cal ib en c3 et donc c'est
un petit souci pour donc là ils ont fait
qu'elle est froide et blanc je pense que
c'était quand même plus logique
d'essayer de faire des quatre assez vite
mais je pense que je n'en ferai jusqu'à
ici six et dix ont cavalé f3 et directe
direct fuji 4 suivi du gros rock avec un
jeu assez agréable mais bon il a fait
cavalier 23 avec les noirs il a joué
sous ses 5 qui justement je pensais pas
terrible fallait plutôt jocaille c6 est
pareil sur des quatre rouges et quatre
avaient transposé dans ce qu'on
regardait juste juste avant parce que
fous ces cinq finalement on a un site
les blancs à faire des cascades dans est
ok certes on va leur créer un option
isolé mais c'est
c'est pas très grave vous pour lequel en
c3 sortir le fouet f1 faire petit rock
et c'est pas mal bon cela dit et blanc
il fait un coup à son tour que j'aime
pas il joue p3 alors je peux concevoir
l'idée c'est évidemment de jouer vous c4
et gagner un temps sur la dame mais mais
bon ça développe pas de pièce sans
corruption et les j'aime pas trop alors
déjà on pourrait jouer le 4 avec les
noirs ici je pense qu'outre complètement
intéressant donc de pousser ses pions
mais il a joué foucher 4 ça va aussi
évidemment on cloue les blancs ont fait
feu deux alors très possible à nouveau
que peut-être poussé quatre soit quand
même le mieux pourquoi parce que mon
attaque la dame et je crois que je vais
dam d'un 24 si on fait un bout comme
d'amd 6 on va se laisser prendre le
piège vous pris 1,27 faut toujours faire
attention danger se clôt avec une pièce
qui peuvent déranger quatre là le fou ce
qu'après reprend il y aurait cavalli
j'ai cinq échecs et dames projet 4 au
coup suivant donc sur fond ces quatre il
faudrait faire de nos 4 10 11 m2 et puis
rentrer dans cette finale alors
évidemment les noirs sont pas du tout en
danger
ness à peu près qu'il est bon avec quoi
les blancs ou verts peut-être key2key c4
à voir quoi
mais je pense équilibré toujours est il
dans la partie surtout g4 il a fait nous
bouffe ou deux assez passifs et qu'il
n'y a pas trop de sens pour moi quand on
a joué 3 6 fév et trois semaines pour
une errance et 4 mais bon ok il lui a
fait 4 donc bien jouer et de prendre
l'espace un tag lecavalier qui bougent
ils échangent en e2 lecavalier se retire
pour un perte de pions centre et kiabi
ces sites voilà très bien petit rock et
cavaliers de 5 alors il se dirige
immédiatement vers à faire le trou en d3
éventuellement et placer une cave on
serait très pénible pour les blancs dans
ce qui est arrivé mais c'est un peu
hâtif
c'était sûr on préfère but d'abord grand
roque et pourquoi pas ensuite cavalier
de cinq premiers en d3
ou d'autres choses mais quand même qu'il
ya 5 c'est clairement lié descoings qui
traînent dans la position
alors il a fait cavalier ou cinq les
blancs qui avaient les f4 attaque la
dame pour un peu la casse des trois
dames des six et il veut le boucher le
trou ans en d4 tout de suite mais c'est
pas génial génial
il fait ici ils avaient à moins de s'en
sortir cette chère dame là qui est
plutôt bien joué attaque le pion bon on
va dire qu'on défend et jouer des quatre
à ce moment alors l'idée c'est quoi
c'est que bon les noirs doivent prendre
en passant puisque mayenne fourchette on
aurait pu on aurait pu jouer qui avaient
libre et donc l'idée de reprendre le
cavalier c'est que sur dang tran détroit
est bondée font plus qu'un oeil aux cinq
donc les blonds reprendrait le fou
devrait couvrir et ça va pas mal pour
les murs ici mais vous faire un
développement c'est ok donc sur calais
prend des trois les noirs ce qui veut
essayer de jouer paul avantage pour des
gens comme ça pour bien défendre le
cavalier pour l'instant y'a pas de f4
pour gagner la pièce bien sûr gallia le
clouage face aux fous et les blancs
devraient plutôt simplifiée position
prendre ici ça me prend on apprend
qu'ils avaient libre en maître le fond
f4 etc et petit à petit de voir
atteindre à peu près d'égalité même
s'ils sont encore un poil moins bien on
vous ferez food & cie sont peut-être des
cavalières 3 qui traîne voilà on reste
dans une position plutôt pas mal le côté
noir
mais evans et donc à noter oui ici on
craint pas forcément toorop son frigo
rock on perd pas de pièce il ya le
maître du couloir en biens est aussi
autre chose à dire c'est quoi c'est que
dans cette position l'autre coup qui
aurait la plus longue qui passait mais
en fait ce qu'elle pense et 5
parce qu'on est pauvre et de reprendre
si vite avec la dame de fer grands axes
d'abord pourquoi avons par contre quel
est le coup d'après si jamais les blancs
veulent le sauver
rencontre sans ça on a le joli galiev
trois échecs suivies d'oedèmes proche
d'eux
ouais donc donc oui bassiste c'est quand
même bien plus mal mais comme le disent
pas prendre ce fou faut prendre le
cavalier la simplifier se bat pour faire
mieux bon tout ça il n'a pas dû c'était
pas évident que vous me direz il a fait
des quatre occupants
à présent place en donc ont gagné un
avion et en plus ils sont bien placés et
plutôt chiant parce qu'ils aillent
prendre l'espace il immobilise un peu
les pièces blanches et tournoi est grand
et bon couverture s'est très très bien
passé pour les noirs on a un pion plus
également cueilli les deux villageois f5
très bien ça évite de se prendre du cac
valeo 4 il fait à quatre et je pense que
son idée c'était de faire des 4es à cinq
ans ferme et vous donc avec les maris
l'a fait à 5 bloquer tout ça cependant
il avait ici une jolie qui de combines
qui était assez écrasante donc si vous
les cherchez vous pouvez c'est très noir
vous pouvez mettre en pause pour les
autres on avance donc de cookies qui
était très forte pour m
pourquoi donc reprend on faisait piéger
quatre échecs
bon le truc c'est que ont fait tchèques
qui entendent attacks aux cavaliers
si les blancs viennent défendre et quake
iii ou préparant le g5 en fait on a
aspiré le roi un peu dans votre camp et
en moi je prends mathé qui avait ici on
peut se développer que le québec est le
problème des blancs en fait c'est qu'on
menace grand dam des 5 août après six
échecs et sur branchez 3 ou fera un
point qu'elle est un cadre donc où il
s'en va on va gagner et sur kg cat et
pas trop de champ au roy et fin d'un
prince qu'à 3 g 1
il ya encore mieux que d'un prince 4
c'est pas en faire de ces cinq échecs et
ce roi chain faire le petit matin à
l'étouffée classique talent d'acteur qui
repart en quoi bien sûr si bien là on le
match en f2 ou manger un bon rush 1
damien ott tour prend et qui arrive de
maths mais toujours sympa ce petit matin
j'ai tout fait voilà donc où il ya
quatre ans quand même 2 était très fort
il a raté mais il a joué ça qui ne gâche
pas là
les blonds fait b4 je comprends puis on
prend sous des quatre tacle à tours
tours b 1
cavalli et 6 alors on pousse au genre de
court jusqu'à la fin de marché à chaque
fois mais comme il a raté une fois bon
ben il a pas il n'a pas forcément les
agents suite cavalli b3 et il a joué
kerry objectif donc attaqué deux ramène
les cavaliers d'un droit à cette opa mal
comprises dame prend aux menaces f2 il a
fait faux trois bons voit prendre ce fou
mais il est parti attaque encore la dame
damas six nouvelles attaques sur age 2
est sûre le cavalier donc cavalier h
trois blocs un peu tout et tourville
tous ressentent donc bilan des
opérations là toujours notre ton plus
des pièces activé et puis le pion bas
c'est un pur en d3 de gaz de dames qui
quelqu'un d'assez far as avec mois
d'attenté de près de trois brèches des
deux bateaux auraient attaqué leur
amener ici tour 2 c'est une option mais
ça a changé pas grand chose non pas en
play offs un peu comme cali ces quatre
îles surprotéger bien des deux et ça
reste sas bien difficile pour les blancs
alors il a fait tour eiffel et caïds et
prend donc une place sa pieuvre
il se donne la possibilité de jouer tour
1 par exemple au prochain coup avec les
bleus est en deçà pions grand dam f3
pour essayer et éventuellement d'aller
rentrer la balle à faire deux trois
échecs mais il l'a bloqué comme ça il y
avait d'autres options mais c'est très
bien alors il lâche le pion à 9,5
mais ramène d'abord 6 propose l'échangé
dame pour entrer dans une finale et une
finale écrasante et d'ailleurs c'est ce
qui va se passer
il eut attaqué sa tour il est venu en
vain ou très classique
maintenant la prochaine étape savent
être de jouer pour refaire dame il a
fait fouillis s'y attaquent le pion il
lui a pris le four puis on prend nos
empreintes f1 et la loi il ya deux
prises possible il a pris du roi si tout
reprend bon y'a plein de pau qui gagne
mais le plus joli ses cavaliers vin
comme ça on bloque la défense à tous
dame qui arrive au couchant pour bien et
si on va prendre fin c'est la partie la
jouer des lycéens de l'autre côté mais
c'est la même chose on immobilise c'est
tout rond qui les font plus la case d1
et puis à la prochain coup ça sera soit
dr dame voilà donc partie bien maîtrisée
de la part de saint-amand qui va qui
aime bien voilà on va se trouver on
verra d'autres parties de ce joueur dans
les prochaines vidéos
à bientôt ciao ciao